Washimi?
I'm going to sleep now.
Isn't it freezing out there?
You'll catch a cold.
Marriage is nothing to aspire to.
You get hitched and then fall out of love
before you know it.
Do you want to live your life
lying to yourself?
What's got into you?
I'm saying that selfish aspirations
hurt you in the end.
What's wrong with having a dream?
And who are you to preach?
You can't know that
until you get married, right?
I did, actually.
Huh?
I know what it's like.
You do?
Yes.
I was married for all of four months.
How did I not know this?
I never told you.
You should have! Aren't we friends?
I didn't feel the need to.
Then why tell me now?
Don't get offended.
I doubt marriage would suit you, Gori.
I'm not deluding myself concerning that.
But are you really one to talk?
Wasn't your marriage a mistake?
What? Mistake?
What are you talking about?
After the divorce,
I was finally able to understand myself.
I look back on it
as a learning experience.
OK, I'll rephrase that.
I'm not interested in the lectures
of a "proud divorcée!"
What are you getting at?
I'm saying that I'm sick
of your anecdotal "advice."
Hey, hey, hey!
Let's not spoil a perfectly good vacation!
See? Look! Look at this!
Look at this!
You're too old to play the "cool girl."
It was just giving you advice,
nothing more.